some new alien nonsense just dropped so
it's our weekly alien distraction here
we go the new alien nonsense some comes
from some scientist who claims that he
has proof possibly of alien life the
subject was moving very fast faster than
95 percent of the Stars near the sun and
it also had material strength tougher
than all the Rocks we had seen over the
past decade in the NASA catalog so there
is a chance I wouldn't quantify it I
would just say it's quite possible that
it's different than a rock and what we
are doing now is analyzing the
composition of the molten droplets that
fell off this object when it was exposed
to the fireball that it created as it
moved through the air and we are getting
some interesting results but I cannot
detail them until we've put them
together in a paper scientific paper
that we hope to make publicly available
to everyone it would mean that we have a
neighbor that we are not alone just like
realizing that you know when you go out
to your backyard and you find a tennis
ball that was thrown by neighbor you
realize yes I do have a neighbor that's
the basic change to our perspective
about our place in the universe and it
will inspire us to explore space it may
make us better instead of fighting with
each other perhaps we'll it will be a
wake-up call for us to realize that
there are more important things in life
than fighting with other people
there it is there is my evidence
that this is BS well there's a lot of
evidence in this BS
but this is my this is the tell for me
so first it's the usual story oh I've
got all this great evidence I can't tell
you about it
yeah but I got man this is some really
great strong evidence we are not alone
we have neighbors it's so clear yeah I
don't have a paper yet or anything but
just take my word for it well I'm gonna
do a paper in the future and then I hope
I can make it publicly available but
anyway before I do any of that I just
want to go on TV and I want to let you
know there are totally aliens totally
and my proof is you should take my word
for it
okay as I say it's always the same old
story oh yeah we've I found a thing
actually my friend's cousin's brother
found a rock in his yard and we know
somehow that it means that there's E.T
out there and so but and he told me I
wish he could be here right now he could
tell you himself but it's just me so
anyway take my word for it
and don't pay any attention to uh the
imprisonment of the opposition leader in
the U.S don't pay attention to your
churches being spied on don't pay any
attention to the prospect of World War
III in Ukraine don't pay any attention
to the haphazard economy that we've got
under Biden don't pay any attention to
the millions of foreigners crossing your
borders no no there's there's I'm
promising you man there's stuff in outer
space
that would complicate if not undermine
your entire traditional cosmology and
your place in the universe but the tell
okay that's all the preface to say the
tell to me that this is a psyop is
he says there at the end he goes well
you know what this would mean
is that look we don't occupy the place
that we think we occupy in the universe
now we traditionally think that we
occupy the center of the universe that
the universe is basically made for us
that there are non-rational creatures
and there is God you know and pure
spirit and that we're right there right
in the middle of it we're the meaning of
those two things and the world was made
for us and we're stewards of that world
we're made in the image and likeness of
God he's saying yeah this is we're going
to disrupt all that
and maybe then we'll stop fighting with
each other
and then maybe we'll just come together
and then maybe we'll just all cooperate
all the time and maybe oh okay so now
after all the BS here my cousin's
brother's friend totally has proof of
aliens you get to the point of it which
is a political point
we're going to change our political
order
we're going to stop fighting we're going
to have to cooperate we got these we're
gonna unite because we got this this
alien invader
and we're going to stop we're going to
have some political changes which
something tells me is what this whole
UFO nonsense has been about from the
very beginning right now go to
goodranches.com use promo code Knowles I
don't know about you but this summer
heat in Nashville feels hotter than it's
been in years thanks to inflation we're
feeling the heat in more ways than one
am I right the one thing that I'm not
sweating this summer though is my meat
price thanks to good ranchers good
ranchers has this insane program where
they lock in your price of meat for two
years which is crazy it's an it's an
amazing deal you should sign up for it
right now I don't know how they're doing
it good ranchers also has just the best
quality meat out there it's so freaking
good I eat it multiple times a week I
love the steaks they've turned me into a
rib eye guy they now have pork very
excited for the bratwurst bundle uh the
burgers are the best I've ever had
they're just it's just an amazing
product at a ridiculously low price and
you can lock in that low price I don't
think I need to say anymore go to
goodranchers.com right now use code
Knowles k w l e s you get 30 bucks off
any box this is 100 American Meat
extremely high quality you're saving a
ton of money goodranchers.com promo code
Knowles goodrancers.com American Meat
delivered Trump keeps going back to
relitigate 2020 which a lot of people
are saying we don't want to hear about
2020. we want to hear about 2024. Trump
keeps returning to this theme
only a party that cheats at elections
would make it illegal to question those
elections it's the only ones that would
really make it
difficult
if you can't challenge a rigged election
think of it we're not looking to do it
we want you know they don't go after the
people that rigged the election they go
after the people that want to find out
what the hell happened it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace now the Geniuses the
total Geniuses and the GOP Consulting
and chattering class they say that any
Republican nominee especially Trump if
he wants to win in 2024 it needs to move
on
from issues like election Integrity has
to move on stop talking about the last
election oh quit going that doesn't pull
well in the suburbs they tell us I don't
know
that is not going to happen that is not
going to especially if the nominee is
Trump especially if Trump continues to
dominate the polls that is not going to
happen
because the chief reason to vote for
Trump
is that you think that things are so bad
that we need a rejection of the system
the chief reason to vote for Trump is
because it is not because you have this
particular view on immigration or that
particular view this particular view on
trade or that particular view it's
because you think that the system is so
corrupt that you can't even trust the
Integrity of the elections the reason to
vote for Trump is that they rigged it in
2020. that's one of the main reasons to
do it the reason to vote for Trump in
2016 is because the Republicans and
Democrats have been working together as
a unit party to advance the same
unpopular and wrong-headed policies on
trade on immigration and on foreign
policy no matter which party got into
Power didn't matter which party got into
Power you always had a lot more
immigrants you always had a lot more
Foreign Wars you always had a lot more
Outsourcing of jobs and materials and
Manufacturing and a lot more neglect of
America's Heartland the Forgotten men
and women the deplorables the
irredeemables and so it was a rigged
game and Trump came in and he said it's
a rigged game and I'm not going to play
by it it's the same thing here with a
particular focus on Election integrity
if you don't think that if you think
that Trump's just a sore loser and
things aren't really that bad and we're
all being hyperbolic then you're not
going to vote for Trump
you're probably going to vote for
DeSantis maybe you're going to vote for
the vague
maybe I don't know maybe if you're
if you really want to return to the
mid-2000s you'll vote for one of the
other candidates
but if you are inclined to vote for
Trump
you particularly want to talk about 2020
and election integrity and if that is
going to lose you the general maybe
that's the tragedy of it I know maybe
that will lose the general maybe that's
that doesn't resonate with voters
but there's no incentive for Trump to
stop talking about that that is the
raison debt of his campaign so glad you
like that clip and it was good but you
got to subscribe to the Michael Knowles
Show YouTube channel ring the bell see
you next time